play each other
but what are we going to do
what we are going to do is
we are going to do 1 dilemma game
you get 1 minute
and you get dilemmas from Albert or mine
you have to choose quickly
you have to choose
don't be silly
u are both great lords
just choose 1 thing
and it must be done within 1 minute
know a little better
yes so don't fit
it really is choosing
they are difficult sometimes
but that's part of it
how are we going to do this
i think the music starts and then uh
we will then start automatically
sir jet u get them all 10
referendum or elected mayor
elected mayor
sigrid kaag of Alexander Pechtold
Like to say it
rule or opposition
rule him or flex
fixed volt of PvdA green links
Volt
cut back or increase the national debt
sometimes you also have to make choices
cut back Ernst coopers from roberdijkgraaf ah
roberdijkgraaf hockey or athletics
politics Netherlands or Europe Europe
solar fields or wind farms
wind farms
at least there are
made quick decisions
certainly because we always test here
there are people flexible in mind who sit here
they can decide quickly
is all important to politicians
mister baudet
are you ready for your question fire
yes yes the dilemmas yes
are you ready
there we go
the music begins
VAT or yes21
VAT Article 1 or Article 23
article 23 branch of shimann zuman
freak Jansen or Gideon van Meijer
Freek Jansen microwave or airfryer
microwave oh well that got difficult
i saw it Russia or USA
Russia lockdown of QR code
lockdown red or white wine
red wine city or region
cut back on the city or increase the national debt economically
well
did you agree